- All righty then, it
is time for Drew's News,
your fresh news linguini in a creamy
(slurps) good news sauce.
And with me at the desk
is my trusty co-pilot, Ross Matthews.
- Yummy, hi everybody.
Hi guys. Hi Drew.
(audience cheers)
- Okay, so first up in the news today
is a little "Keeping Up
With the Kardashians",
although I don't believe
that's what we're calling it anymore
because they are back with a new show,
proving they are yet again an open book.
So just last summer,
they said goodbye
to the old "Keeping Up
With the Kardashians"
after 20 seasons.
That's a very round number.
But now People reports that they are back
and bearing all the goods
on "The Kardashians",
which is their new reality series
coming to Hulu on April 14th,
and we have a trailer hot off the presses.
Take a look.
(upbeat music)
- [Kim] Over the last year
we have seen such
transformations in all of us.
- Yes.
- This is day one.
- Okay.
(audience cheering)
Yeah, I know.
(audience applauding)
I mean-
- Ross.
- Yes?
- You gonna watch?
- Uh, you think?
Yeah, I'm gonna, are you all gonna watch?
Hello, I wanna know.
(audience cheering)
You know what's so interesting
about their show always
is we know kind of in the headlines,
the pop culture headlines,
what's going on with them.
But then when the show
airs we get to go deep
and think about what's been
going on lately with them.
I mean, Kim hosted SNL,
then the Pete Davidson,
then the Kanye of it all,
then the Tristan of it all,
then Kylie with the baby and
the Courtney and the Travis.
Hello, I want all the deets
and they're gonna serve it up,
I know they will.
- I never watched the original show
'cause I'm not the biggest
reality TV person as you know.
But I feel like if you
didn't watch the show,
and I've always followed that.
I'm right up with,
I do keep up up with the Kardashians.
And you don't have to
watch the television show
to be an aficionado of them
because they're everywhere.
But I feel like this one I could jump into
because we're kind of up to date
and there's so much going
on and maybe it's a 2.0.
- It is 2.0 and it's
not like the "Godfather"
where you have to have
watched the first one
to get the second one.
You don't have to have to have watched
"Keeping Up With the
Kardashians" to get this one.
You can just jump in-
- Which I am one of those
psychological persons
where I'm like oh, there's
19 years I gotta catch up on.
Forget it.
This one is a fresh
start, so I think I'm in.
- I'm in too.
All right, we'll be
watching that coming up.
All right, next up we've got
a man from New Jersey Shore
who got a shocking seafood surprise.
Listen to this.
The New York Post reports
Michael and Maria Spressler
were out at their favorite
restaurant in Cape May
called The Lobster House
when Michael ordered his
usual clam appetizer, delish.
Except this time on the 12th clam
he bit down on something really hard.
And as you can imagine, Michael thought,
"Oh no, I lost a tooth."
But when he spit it out it was a pearl.
A pearl.
It turns out the 8.8 millimeter pearl
could be worth thousands of dollars.
Now that's what we call
winner, winner clam dinner.
The only thing a clam
ever gave me was diarrhea.
Thanks so much.
He gets a pearl, that is
winning the appetizer lottery.
- I know, I love,
thank God he didn't swallow it.
- I know, can you imagine?
Even if I swallowed it I'd
still be getting it back.
(audience laughing)
I don't wanna go into details but
they're deciding if Michael's
wife is gonna make it
into a piece of jewelry,
and he was like "Well,
let's get it appraised first
"before we do that."
- Oh, I say sell and collect the clams!
- Hey! Yes, I'm (indistinct) you.
(upbeat music)